hi my name is Kamel nanjiani and I feel
skeptical about being Conan O'Brien's
best friend well oh wow you added best
friend oh my god
well guess what oh my God guess what I
don't really have a best friend you
don't have a you could be in the running
are you looking I am I bring a lot to
the table you know what first of all you
do you are you are very talented
um I've been enjoying your comedy you're
a hilarious person uh thank you and
you've had this incredible career Arc I
would be proud to call you my best
friend and there's a couple of people
out there listening right now who think
they're my best friend yeah like Timothy
Olyphant I know exactly yeah is it
really him no he's not my best friend I
love Timothy Oliphant but he's been
getting a lot of play recently because
we released a Jordan video you know
which we haven't released in a while we
released a Jordan video because Jordan
has been making Cameo appearances on the
side George Lansky and we made a video
or I rip into him for that and he starts
he comes right back at me and his
um his repost his angry comeback is I
know you have your celebrity friends you
have your dinners with Timothy Oliphant
people really like that line and I know
for a fact because I get contacted uh
right after that video came out
hours after it came out I'm contacted by
lin-manuel Miranda and it's a quote and
it says you have your dinners with
Timothy all of that exclamation point
and he said this this is burning a hole
in my brain this this uh that Jordan
shouted this at you you guys are one of
the famous friendships those famous
friendships like you know Melanie and
Pete Davidson is a famous friendship
right there are like famous friendships
and I feel like you and Timothy Oliphant
are I want it to be
um I love that guy but uh you know he's
he'll go off for seven months at a time
he's a working actor in demand and he'll
be making a movie in Wales and I don't
see him and I can't have that in the
best friend you I know are very busy but
I'll I'll be around I'm you know you'll
make time yeah that sounds so Sinister
snake the time it's very needy yeah
Unbreaking eye contact you haven't
blinked for the last three months my
eyes are painted on
I'm a creepy doll in a museum yeah
um it's so much fun because you came by
this happened so often but uh it's the
nature of this gig but you came by about
10 minutes ago to record the podcast and
you and I started talking comedy and TV
shows and
um I'm a massive my son and I are
massive fans of Silicon Valley and we
re-watch it and kind of study it we love
it so much we were talking about that we
were talking about The Simpsons we were
talking about all kinds of stuff and
people around us and saying why why
aren't we recording this but we you know
you're one of those people who the
minute I see you I feel like oh Camille
and I could talk for maybe like four
hours I feel things we like that's so
great to hear because I feel the same
way about you and the last time we ran
into each other was at a restaurant
exactly you introduced me to Martin
Short and Liza who I don't think I had
met before she's lovely yep and Martin
Short I was you know very very excited
to me what a nice guy yeah it was a
really sweet moment because
um Liza my wife and I were having dinner
with Martin Short and
um you came in and you had your own
Posse at the table you had you had a
cool group together I had a nice group
you came by you said Hi and then you
walked away and then when I went oh I
was like would you introduce Martin shot
you would like come by so I went over
like you asked me and that was sweet
because it was a nice moment because you
were so sweet about oh my God if you
could just introduce me to Martin Short
that would be like a nice I've never met
him and so it was one of those nice
moments in life where all I had to do
was say oh
um Marty come on who and you know he was
very happy to meet you I did nothing
except but I felt you treated me as if I
had done you this huge favor even though
all I did was now that I think about it
you didn't do very much I didn't do
anything maybe you should be best
friends with Martin Short yeah I feel
like we would we would could have a good
famous friendship going because he's a
very nice giving man I don't know what
do you mean giving man hold on a second
yeah a giving man I love contrast
that's how it was that's how it was laid
out well what I mean is when I met him I
think he understood how much he meant to
me and so he was like extra kind because
he knew that him being nice to me would
mean a lot to me yes and the other thing
that happened was this is going to feel
like a name drop but you you you came
you you said hi to people at our table
there was a gentleman sitting next to me
and you talked to him for a while good
to see you whatever and then he went and
sat down when I came
met Martin Short he was lovely and then
you were like hey who's the guy sitting
next to you and I said you and McGregor
wow I didn't recognize that it was you
and McGregor yeah big beard he had a big
beard and it was a it was Outdoors
because it was still one of those
coveted situations famously hard to see
Outdoors
tonight with bad light
ing he was wearing a t-shirt t-shirt
said I'm Ewing McGregor and I
recognize him right away I just said hi
I was very pleasant to him and also I'm
going to say this you were very pleasant
and you didn't listen to him I stood
behind I was be I was talking to you he
had his back to me and I kind of did one
of those highs around the corner thing
so I didn't really get a good look at
him I swear to God that Scottish accent
and those eyes he didn't say my hair he
didn't say much act like you recognized
him no I thought he was I I was I was
just being very polite to a human being
you were being very polite and I didn't
realize that you didn't recognize him
and like you did a good job and
obviously as soon as it went back I was
like hey by the way he had no idea who
you were I'm joking yeah I didn't do
that but I did not do that I've
interviewed Ewan McGregor I love you and
McGregor I love his work but I was when
I saw him I didn't get a good look at
his face he has a big beard it's dark
out yeah
no but he had a lightsaber at the time
yeah but he wasn't wearing a kilt he
didn't have a Tamil Center
why are you directing it outwards
you know he wasn't saying uh can you
score me some heroin for my heart and
train spotting I mean things that were I
like that you needed clarification for
what movie you were referencing the most
famous heroine movie that is that
introduced us to you and McGregor really
is it the most famous heroine movie yeah
there's so many what I think Wizard of
Oz is a heroin movie okay the Hobbies
the poppies I mean I'm sorry they all
get high on the poppy field I mean you
could have said uh Requiem for a Dream
which is obviously like a like a drug
movie but I want to say you said
something to me at that thing when that
I thought was by the way who is Ewan
McGregor oh God oh my God Matt's gonna
explode right now you're talking about
Obi-Wan Kenobi oh please no that was
Alec Guinness
wasn't he Obi-Wan Kenobi yeah but come
on you know oh let me guess did they
make other Star Wars movies afterwards
yeah oh don't mess with perfection I
like that you're attacking you and
McGregor the one guy who is not at fault
here yeah really I'm really not
attacking him I swear to God and you and
I know you're a big fan of the podcast
and you're listening I am not attacking
you I'm sorry you had a giant beard you
were not wearing overtly stereotypical
Scottish attire which I think is the job
of anyone from Scotland you recognized
me because I was wearing a show marker
at that time you were yes yes and I had
a map of Pakistan with an arrow pointing
and it said Homeland yes how do you know
who he is today because when he walked
when he walked in he was holding again
the aforementioned map that had a big
map of Pakistan and it said Homeland
yeah so that helps me those things yeah
and I brought the traditional sweets of
my people yes that's what uh Sona did
when I first met her she brought me the
traditional dried pomegranate and
apricot of the Armenian people yeah and
you're like oh you're Armenian let's let
me make fun of you I would never never
do that you can't get away with that in
this day and age and I never was voted
in this country in a basket so not true